i mean i got no bad guys just that i
make bad decisions and bad choices you
know so
i'm trying to get my thinking right i
guess
that's all right ed yes sir ed where'd
you grow up where are you from i'm
originally from georgia
i'm originally from a place called macon
georgia
tell me about your family um
the only family at the time when i was
growing up that i knew was my mom was a
single thing i go back further than that
it's uh my mom had me by a black guy uh
back in the 1970s and that wasn't
tolerated back there so basically for a
long time her family disowned her
because she had a baby outside of the
races your mom was white my mom's white
yes and um
growing up um i was five years well
before that uh did you know your dad i
never met my dad no i never met my
father i asked my mom where where my
father was when i was about five years
old and uh she asked me to have a seat
and um she said that uh he went to uh
get something to celebrate after she
found out that after he found out that
she was pregnant and he never came back
so i've never i've never seen my father
and um growing up my mother used to work
as a waitress and
she used to have brain guys over and
guys used to come in my room touching on
me and feeling on me and and i used to
tell my moms and and she didn't want to
believe me at the time
not that it was important but it was a
yeah like white guys are black guys
i'm sorry these are white guys or black
guys uh it was it was basically all she
she was basically bringing all on
basically she was doing white black
mexican latino basically uh yeah it was
like a spread of them no particular
races in flavors yes sir yes
basically yes sir
so it put it put in my head that my own
family didn't want me you know so i was
like in a tumble so uh my mom went to
the uh the the military uh when i was
when i was turning like 13 when i mean
like nine i'm sorry and she met a guy
that was in the marines and and they hit
it off pretty good and later on he
became my stepfather and i traveled with
him a lot over the years but some of the
times i went with my um
my grandparents and they stayed in
tallahassee florida
and uh
when i got like 15 or so uh i got into
it with my step dad and uh i ran away
and i went to uh houston texas
and uh i was in a place called acres
homes in north north houston and um
like i had i had so much anger with with
my mom and my dad you know and and build
up a
and that i i shot a guy when i was like
15. and and and they caught me and i
went went to prison like i was on the
run for a while i went to prison when i
was like 18
and i did like 16 years on that
yeah and and i mean i in in the prison i
had like did you kill him
yeah he got yeah i killed him yes
and uh
in prison i was in in so many any fights
and
and and then you get like uh
you know
people touching you and doing the
showers and stuff you know it's just
crazy [ __ ] but
so i mean it had me
messed up for a while i mean i was like
questioning myself for a long time it's
like
if if my own parents don't love me i
mean then [ __ ] nobody loves me
and um
so i had
before and you know i was like
13 or so uh go back a few minutes i had
my my cousin he was my best friend in my
whole whole world at the time you know
and um
he got he got shot in the back of the
head he was walking from the store and
uh he died in my arms you know he got
shot in the back of the head with it
with a straight bullet of a 12-gauge
shotgun and he blowed his head over and
uh he died in my arm and my grandfather
was it wasn't meant for him i'm sorry
the bullet was not meant for him it was
not meant for him no it was not at the
time no no he wasn't meant for him he
was a good dude he was he he was always
in schools he me and him was totally
opposite see i didn't like school at all
if i wouldn't have went to prison i
don't even think i would have graduated
i wouldn't got a ged or anything where'd
you go in regular school
i'm i never went i mean it was boring to
me i mean i always skipped school went
out and got high i got drunk or whatever
the case may be i mean i never even went
to school i never liked at school from
from middle school to all the way up to
high school i never liked the school i
mean it was just so boring to me time
consuming waste of time is what i
thought basically i mean i i felt like
my own parents didn't
didn't love me didn't want me around or
anything and
like it's like my grandparents was like
the worst at the time because it's like
they was like
truly like fed up that that my mom went
with a black guy and had a baby where
they kept the baby because i heard that
they wanted her to have an abortion or
whatnot but she didn't have the abortion
so they that really pissed them off so
it's like they disowned her and and they
took her out of everything so she was
like
living from from friend to friend's
house and living on couches and
and living on the floors and
i mean like i said eventually she went
to the military and got a life together
and got a life on track
and and like i said at the time so she
she got the uh the step there he was
cool he's a cool dude but at the time i
didn't want to hear it you know because
i was thinking that i was the man of the
house so we got into it and blows went
into uh to it so
and and i was like i'm out of here so
like i said i went to houston i was in
houston texas for like 28 years and
getting in trouble from left and right i
mean from petty stuff to like stealing
shoes from somebody or going in the
house and doing like serious serious
crime of like kicking people doors in
with a 12-gauge shotgun just arrived
just just just to get my high feel you
know i mean i used to
and and the one that got me the worst
was uh it was an elderly people like i
said i was like
17 18 when i got shot caught up on that
one and um
i i shot this guy and
it wasn't intended to shoot him but it
happened
and like i said i was on the run for
like three years or so and they caught
me when i was like 17 and a half almost
18 and
they gave me 16 years for that and
so you killed who
it was um
one it was uh basically it was one of
the guys that that i saw that that was
when i was younger that that i
recognized in my mind that that was him
and and i wasn't like trying to
[Music]
ask him any questions or not i was just
trying to
get rid of him basically so i just
wanted to wound him or scare him or
something but the bullet it went here
basically
went through his heart
so
they gave me like i said 16 years so i
went in the penitentiary and uh
at a young age and they trialed me as an
adult
and they said that i needed protection
while i was in so basically when i
that's basically how
i got basically involved in gang
activity and gang violence and you were
in prison when i was in prison yeah
because they said you need and that's
when you had to do a lot of uh what i
say uh mold work or what now you had to
do a lot of i had to do i did do some
killing when i was in the penitentiary
too i killed like four people when i was
in just just to prove myself to them
that i was loyal as they say but kind of
with a shank you make a shank out of the
prison you stab them you can stab them
in the lunch line child line you can you
stab them in the shower
stop them whenever they're doing counts
on the on the hall
and uh who are your victims
uh basically uh it was um
basically my own color basically black
and uh latino basically
was uh
for what reason were they were they
uh
two uh basically because the person
owned it they wanted them to uh have
them out so that they could take over
what they was doing because basically
they were selling the drugs in the uh
the fruits
they were selling uh the mexican
basically they were selling basically
the
cocaine and uh the uh
the heroin and they were splitting that
up with uh
getting rid of the competition
pretty much
they cut after a while they gave me the
uh
the the name of uh street sweeper
basically so because if
the person had a problem they just
called it
to alleviate it and i got bored so that
was my thing man it's like i didn't have
nobody my own family didn't love me so
nobody in this damn world is going to
love me so i was like in a spiraled down
and believe it or not i actually got
married
and uh i was married for a minute you
know i was married
and uh
my wife got killed in front of me
you know and uh that that that was
another thing that i cussed god out i
cussed everybody out and it's like i
like damn it's like nothing is going
right in my world it's like every time i
meet somebody that that that's good or
every time that the things is going
right in my life it's like boom they're
taking away from me it's like what it's
like that song is so true only the good
die young and and that's a suck
statement and i said i mean i had words
with god and i'm like what the hell god
i'm like why the hell you gonna take her
like she's a good woman you know i mean
my wife she was uh mexican and cuban and
and and it's like every time she get
married she'll she'll uh
talk all that and i said i don't speak
that man speak english and know she get
mad but you know but yeah it's like she
was my best friend though you know she
was good she was a good woman and and
that that that made me like you know
what i'm saying harden my heart i guess
against god
and and like what the hell is really
going on here it's like my cousin got
killed and he was like in the school and
all of that and and my wife she got
killed and she was a good woman i mean
she was a faithful woman and i was the
[ __ ] and i was still here and i don't
i didn't i didn't understand it and i
just kept questioning
why
why things was what's happening in
that's that fashion
and and like i said after that it's like
i just got into a heartless you know
it's like it's like we only live to die
you know so i did i closed myself up i
didn't want to get close to nobody after
that but my wife she got killed by a
drunk driver
she was getting off of work she worked
in a
hospital she worked in the hospital in
dallas texas
and she was getting off of work and
getting in a court
and i was going to go to surprise her
basically in an underground garage and a
drunk driver
came
and he was going like at least 80 miles
an hour or so because her car was
basically
at an angle
and he was coming in the wrong way
and she was at her driver's
door getting in
and he basically he ran into the door
and he cut her literally in half because
he smashed the door into her and he cut
her in half and the front part of her
went on his car and and the rest of it
went back at the core and
yeah it's it's like and then that was
like right in front of me it's like
i it's like it just made me like
question everything it made me question
existing question life question god
and and
like i said i just closed up and i
started just going on around the world
it's like i just basically just just
shut down and just
went over every state of the united
states
it's like um
yeah and uh
i went to uh nine countries and i went
to uh the baddest one that i liked was
okinawa japan i learned uh
i got my i got a black belt in uh uh
okinawa
and uh
man it's like uh i had a um a cousin
growing up too it's like
she was raped in front of me she was
gang raped in front of me
and uh they they they held me down
and and i made me watch
and uh this happened in where houston
i'm sorry where did this happen
this happened in georgia
um this was when i was younger this was
when i was like 12 or so and she was
like 15 or 16 at the time
and um
yeah they they raped her and it was like
10 of those guys and they they made me
sit there and watch that
and um
they said that's how me and um
and uh i told the guys about that when i
was in in prison because that's when i
got in and basically uh they came back
and they had they got this dude
and that was crazy uh they they got this
guy and uh they they tied him
basically they they they put him in a
burn a old abandoned building
and uh they they nailed his balls to the
to the
to the floor
and uh they gave him a butter knife and
and set the building on fire
and and and he burned it he burned the
death and in the fire
and uh i mean like i said i went on i
went on years and years with that
because they showed me love you know
they showed me support
what's the significance of a butter
knife
it was just uh like basically throw it
in his face you know the lab and to pull
your nuts off and die
pretty much you know oh i see yeah yeah
yeah because i mean he wanted to rape he
wanted to rape somebody i mean this dude
was was like in his 20s or something he
raped it you know so i mean but yeah
it was crazy but like i said it's like
um
i i went that way yeah but it's like at
the time i was so confused in my head
you know what i'm saying having guys
come in my room and and
and
and touch me at a young age you know i i
was confused myself you know i didn't
know what what the hell to expect and
then my own mom wouldn't believe me and
my own dad wouldn't even stay in my life
having
separation and abandonment issues i mean
it's like i was just basically tore up
from the floor so it's like it made my
heart and
just just
freeze up on me and just made me
not want to be around anyone or anything
so i mean like i say i was in texas
after texas i i went to a place called
lincoln lincoln nebraska and uh lincoln
nebraska it was cool this [ __ ] but it
snows like a mug out there
and um i mean it was just these people i
mean it's like a college town man and
and i got into the to the meth out there
real bad too so i started i started
robbing stores out there i started
kicking in stores i started breaking in
stores i started breaking in houses and
stuff out there it's it's just crazy and
then that brought me up into uh
homelessness i lost lost my job out
there and then basically
back on the streets again i mean so i
mean it's like it's been a turtle
turmoil for me it's like try to do the
right thing like i say i take one step
forward and and a thousand steps
backwards you know so
yeah it's it's been it's been it's been
a turnaround what is your drug today
that's good bro oh my drug today i i try
to keep it i smoke meth still but i try
to try not to smoke as much my drug
today is like a weed basically yeah
weed and alcohol pretty much has your
life improved or
become worse become worse since you've
been on skid row
i mean
i think it it it's coming becoming more
and more
worse i think because i mean i've lost
my id i've lost
all my documents like more than one time
i had lost so many phones
and stuff i mean it's pretty bad out
here i mean
when you when you fall asleep after
being up for five days on crystal meth
you'll you'll lose it yeah you lose
everything that's so true that is so
true that is everybody and i i had a
tent burn up them i had somebody set my
tent on fire with a with me in it you
know and i had a can of butane right
right this guy must have been looking
out for me on that night yeah i was i
was over on uh
fifth and crocker where i had that tent
and uh somebody came and they they
they set my tent on fire and i had a can
of butane right beside the where they
set the fire at
and and it didn't blow up uh so that let
me know that god was looking out for me
on that day
you know and and
and even here i mean i had so much anger
so much rage out here that that people
was uh stealing from me i used to go
around
beating people here with a two by four i
mean i used i hit like five or six
people in the head like like two by
fours and
and brass knuckles and stuff like that i
mean i i had you you're collecting debts
or you were just going crazy i was just
losing my freaking mind out there dude
it's like people were stealing from me
and i'm like i didn't know if it was my
own friends that so-called friends say
that they was doing it or whoever was
doing it because they was helping me
look for it but they didn't seem like
they cared about anything that was
stolen or anything so i mean
was it was crazy and then when i was
here over by the la mission i got
stabbed over there twice
and uh i got shot three times here i got
shot at uh gladys park and i got shot at
san julian park and then i got shot down
about a midnight mission and uh that was
like [ __ ] the first time was like 2016
2018 and 2020 like two years apart
you know and it's not your time yet
i hope not man because i ain't ready yet
for real i mean god is good that's all i
can say man i mean it's like through all
the detroit i got two kids uh and uh
i put my kids through a lot of crazy
stuff too man it's like
it's like um
i
i would always be drunk high
you know i wouldn't be fit enough for
them to even communicate with i can't
even talk to my own kid it's like
my daughter was uh 18 you know my kids
don't drink they don't they don't do
drugs or anything they don't even smoke
cigarettes you know that's that's a
blessing
but uh my daughter was she's 28 now my
daughter was uh 18 she said dad i love
you
and i always love you but i don't like
you no more she said you you act like an
[ __ ] and i don't want to see you
anymore if i have kids you'll never see
my kid and she said that [ __ ] and she
meant that too she had grandkids she got
kids i mean
and and i haven't seen my grandkids yet
and um
i haven't seen i got a two-year-old
grandson and i got a four-year-old
granddaughter i see him on um on duo or
video chat but i haven't i haven't seen
him yet you know and uh
i mean that's another thing that that
goes inside you know goes in my head
it's like damn i mean i haven't seen my
dad and now i haven't seen my grandkids
you know and i got a son that's in uh
dallas texas he does uh video game
repairs and stuff like i said my kids is
a total opposite of me though
but um like i said growing up
in my life i mean like i said
it made me question a lot about myself
and today i'm still questioning myself i
mean it's like if my own parents didn't
love me or wouldn't love me enough to
defend me or stand up for me or like if
they support me then then
who the hell in this world with it and
and it shows i mean this world has
basically been kicking my ass where i
i've been basically
been getting the short end of the stick
or i just been
doing what i feel is right survival
survival mode i've been living in
survival mode my whole life
so yeah basically ed whatever you say is
your biggest regret in your life my
biggest regret
hurting my wife and my kids
and hurting my mom that's my biggest
regret right there because my
yes disappointing them yeah letting them
down all the time telling them i
wouldn't do this and do it again
man i'm hugging on my mind so many times
in a in a juvenile jail cell and in a
prison jail cell and
and and i mean it's just crazy i mean i
just wanted to do the right thing
and it always backfired and blow up in
my face so
i i need to change my way of thinking
you know but like i say it's who i used
to grow up with because acres homes and
uh fifth ward and houston texas i mean
that's not that's not really good you
know i mean you got a lot of you got a
lot of what they call them gorillas out
there and they hungry you know they
hungry they hungry
and if you ain't got no money and you
put a [ __ ] out there with no money
they're gonna do whatever it takes to
get it you know that's why they say we
stay hungry you know and and and i mean
like i say i i like right up here i
slept right up here by the wine gordon
and i seen a dude get hit in the head
with a with a 2x4 with a nail through it
right in his head right here and i mean
oh wait and i went to sleep and i mean
that night somebody was looking out for
me then because
nobody nobody said nothing that did
nothing to me didn't i and like i said
it's it's been crazy
i'm sorry how old are you
me
me i'm 51 you're 51. yes sir
you still have time to make changes i
hope so i hope so i hope so because i'm
getting tired of busting my head in the
in the rocks i'm tired of doing the same
old repeat over and over again you know
but yeah like i said god god god must
not be finished with me yet and but like
i said i had a lot of questions
regarding i still do got that
questioning when i'm like why is he
letting my cousin die who ain't done
nothing and my wife died who hasn't done
anything my grandfather i can understand
that that dude lived to be 104 years old
but he was like the coolest dude i ever
met in my life he was like superman to
me he couldn't read or write but he was
in world war ii he was man he was he was
everything but yeah when this dude died
i cried for like
[ __ ] two to three weeks man when he did
that he was he was like the coolest dude
ever
and
it's
and i mean like i said we just went on a
spree after my grandfather it's like
just drinking and going down it's like
drinking
like
scrapping going into abandoned buildings
breaking into people houses
i mean it's just it just went from one
thing to the next and i mean then the
drugs got even harder and
started i started shooting up i started
doing heroin back then real bad and then
i stopped that [ __ ] i'm glad i did
and uh but i started back with the meth
and then i started with the alcohol i
said then i needed to feel my fuel
because i couldn't work because like i
couldn't work like i didn't want to work
like i didn't feel right being around
people you know it's like like like
people was just looking at me or or
judging me or
you know like like like
you know just talking and talking about
me and then every time they laugh it's
like made me feel some type of way and
and it's like i didn't i didn't know how
to approach it and i didn't know how to
deal with it so so it just made me made
me more angrier and angrier and and one
time i i went to
to work
and and i took two pistol
pistols with me to work because i
thought people were actually talking
about me i thought people was was
actually trying to to to to plot against
me to to do something and and i was
shooting up in the in the top of the the
break room basically and and
they called the police on me there and
and i tried to run out the window and
they basically they they broke me down
and
took me to jail on that one but the the
worst is one that made me like mad with
the police too is i was in houston texas
and i was like
before i got arrested i was like 15 and
a half and and i was bigger than this i
was way bigger and
i uh
i got pulled into by a mistaken identity
as they call that crap and they pulled
me up they put the zip ties on the back
of my arms and my legs and then they put
the handcuffs on me and they threw me in
the alley and i mean it was like ten of
them and then they beat me with those
sticks i mean they they beat the dog
i was in the hospital for like six
months man the cops said this cops yeah
yeah beat the dog crap out of me you you
weren't even guilty no i wasn't even
nowhere near that i was nowhere around
all that
and it was crazy man it was crazy but i
was on i was on the streets in houston
texas for about a year about two and a
half years
and uh i got in with um
swisher house swisher house uh that was
the biggest recording
uh thing uh back in the day
but now they got more of them i started
out with security with them you know and
uh
that was sweet that was pretty cool man
because uh you get the you get the fight
show off your your
skills and stuff out there and
this dude was was drunk one time hit him
and broke out two of his teeth
you know and and i i started to to to
start a light
seeing people in pain you know because
it took away my pain i guess i don't
know but i started i started liking that
stuff so then i started basically just
trying to start fights everywhere i go
back you know and and
it was crazy because i mean i was just
fighting people for no apparent reason
just starting to fight with people just
just putting people in the hospital for
no reason and and just just just using
just uh taking advantage of the uh the
ability that i was taught you know and
and it was it was starting to get
too much for me you know it's like too
much it's like people expect too much
from you you know if they want you this
this this
but but you're not you're not really
willing to do all of that so you said
nah then you get back homeless again and
then yeah you know it's it's just crazy
ed what would you say is the uh
the most important lesson you've learned
in your 51 years i'm sorry what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your 51 years my
important lesson is to to to to slow
down and smell the roses to be grateful
um
and and family family first you know and
for a long time growing up i thought i
thought my family was a boy i thought my
family was was was a waste of time i
thought my family you know didn't didn't
really love me or didn't care but but
you know i didn't didn't really know it
all like that i didn't i didn't know
everything that i thought i knew and
and and what i read what i really
learned in life is is to just slow down
and smell the roses basically and to be
grateful and and and today
and tomorrow's not guaranteed and the
next five minutes is not guaranteed and
from what i've seen i've seen so many so
many friends and so many family members
just just die for no reason or get
killed for no reason and uh yeah that's
what making me learn now to be grateful
and just slow down
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you i wish you the best
of luck from here on out thank you so
much thank you man that was a blessing
you have a great day
you